we were scheduled to do a podcast um
your publicist was like I'm at your
house I'm like I'm just straight up at
the Jimmy Kimble program like the only
thing that was uh funny about it is I
had to pee soet so I did end up peeing
on your wall and as I'm doing it an
Amazon delivery driver comes up and I'm
Midstream so I just I didn't stop by the
way that's the by the way that's the
only way Amazon drivers are allowed to
pee too so he's is this where we pee
right exactly too but that was the
funniest little moment with it I'm like
like I don't know if I gave him a little
like hey what's up but but I definitely
was like like I felt so weird as he just
walking right by me just continuing to
pee obsessed I love you